-Our first guest tonight
is a Grammy nominated musician
and actor who stars in the
second season of "Homecoming,"
which premiers this Friday
on Amazon Prime Video.
Here's my conversation
with Janelle Monáe.
Janelle, how are you?
It's lovely to see you again
-Hi, Seth, how are you?
-I'm doing very well.
This is your first time
on the show.
But we -- I want to say very
quickly, with met in 2010.
I hosted the ESPYs,
and you were the musical act
And never in my life,
when I heard you guys rehearse
had I thought, "Oh, my goodness.
This person is going to be ver
famous, very quickly.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I don't know
if that's good or bad, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
-It was -- it was very good.
It was very good.
-Thank you.
-I wanted to ask,
you pulled off something
very impressive in the times
we are living through.
You did a "Vanity Fair" cove
shoot that is stunning
that you did through Zoom,
which I had no idea
you could have this qualit
of work through Zoom.
-Me either. [ Laughs ]
I was very nervous about going
into it because I'm thinking
"Oh, my goodness.
This is a cover
for "Vanity Fair," a dream
And I couldn't use my glam team.
You know, nobody was --
-Yeah.
-I had to do my own hair,
my own makeup, and you know,
they -- I consulted with my team
like before we start shooting.
But it was an amazing experience
working with Collier,
working with all of the women.
A lot of women came together
to pull this shoot,
and one of the notes that th
photographer was saying
of just how intimate everythin
was, she was like,
"Janelle, you're not breathing
I can feel through the --
[ Laughter ]
I can feel that you're not
breathing. Breathe."
And so, I mean, it was --
it's, I mean,
what a time we're living in,
right?
-Well, it's so funny,
because, you know,
the thing about photo shoots
is even when a photo
looks intimate, you've bee
on so many,
you know that there are so man
people standing around.
And this was a case where,
I don't know,
like, you realize, oh,
this is actually more authenti
via Zoom than it would be
anywhere else.
It's a really --
they're really wonderful photos.
-Yeah, thank you so much.
Thank you.
It was a dream for sure.
-You -- We obviously know you as
a musician, a singer,
a film actor,
so this is your first --
"Homecoming" is your first
television work.
This is the second season
of a fantastic show.
What drew you to
wanting to do it?
-Well, I was a fan
of the first season.
I think we all were so excited
when Julia Roberts
said she was coming to TV.
And I watched that.
I listened to the podcast.
And I just love what it
had to say about, you know
corporate greed,
about corporate greed
and capitalism
and the hiding of information.
I love the fact that this season
I got an opportunity to play
this woman named Jackie,
who wakes up in the middle
of a boat with no clue,
no memory of who she is.
And so we go on this journey
of self-discovery.
Her uncovering her identity, and
it's a psychological thriller.
It has this Hitchcockian vib
to it.
The music, the score,
just everything
that it had to say
felt so timely and was don
so artfully
that it just feels like
an outlier in TV.
And so, it just made me --
it made me
want to be a part of the show.
-It is a wonderful show.
It's a wonderful mystery.
And I love a 30-minute drama
I don't want to make it soun
like --
-Right.
-I don't love hour-long dramas
-Yes.
-But I feel in a interesting
narrative structure.
It has great cliff hangars
And I highly recommend it.
-Oh, my goodness. Listen,
that means so much from you.
-[ Laughs ]